all right we've got a lot of blue sky
out there we're taking a break from the
extreme heat
but it's still going to be hot so i
don't want to mislead you in any way
and we've got those southwest breezes
especially up through the mountains this
morning and out at red rock
we're still 90 degrees we tied the
record of 113
yesterday so no more one teams but
temperatures will stay above normal you
can see how
the camera's shaking around a little bit
only 12 percent humidity
and dew points in the 30s we're going up
to 107
the normal average high comes down today
to 103.
so yes still above normal but thank
goodness we're not looking to tie
records that one's 114 for today
so breezy to gusty southwest winds we'll
come back for most valley neighborhoods
today
and the extreme heat at least breaks
down to below 110 as we get through the
weekend the back to school forecast
again temperatures will stay above
normal next week
there is a little rain up in the
northwest the intermountain west
not enough to put out those wildfires
which are raging
in so many western states but they're
getting a little relief and it's
mountain fest
up at lee canyon tomorrow it's going to
be a lot of fun today it's
still going to be pretty windy some
breezes up there tomorrow but shouldn't
be as strong
attempts in the 70s at lee canyon 80s
for kyle canyon 108 and
rough winds for the lake today so please
be careful and just want to give you a
little
reason to watch the skies not for
thunderstorms but for the perseids
meteor shower
which peaks uh during the week next week
but the weekend
in the overnight hours much easier to
stay up late on the weekend to maybe
catch some shooting stars it's one of
the best meteor shower shows of the year
107 a day 108 tomorrow back to school
we're staying
a little hot at 106 on monday between
105 and 107
all next week